hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to toss the turtle if you
don't know what toss the turtle is
you've literally been living under a
rock for the entirety that you've been
in school or near a computer in your
entire life it is an amazing game and
everyone has probably played it and I'm
gonna send this turtle into goddamn
space just because I can if you know
like these types of games these have
been done forever and this game kind of
takes forever to get through but I'm
going to show you how a pro shoots a
goddamn turtle wink wink hub in the
blink okay so starting out we're not
gonna be doing - very good unless we get
extremely lucky with the things that we
hit on I got shot which is a nice little
feature I am so good at this one I don't
know what that's gonna do me boink
oh and that's just about the end of our
story here so this is actually a really
good first one
not bad for me I earned six hundred and
fifty one dollars not bad at all so this
game was made on new grounds by it was
made by forever cool and gonzo so
they're good they're good guys and
they've done a lot of stuff so basically
you shoot your turtles down the road and
you blast them into bits with you're
gonna goo and you somehow get money from
doing this activity it's the world's
most cruel and amazing job that ever
existed so with that being said I'm
gonna take a drink of water because I am
practically overheating so oddly enough
judging by the screen I can only assume
that it's actually the turtle that's
spending money to toss himself farther
down the road and I don't know what the
benefit of that would be but it's good
enough for me okay so I can afford dick
I can afford dick diddly but I can't
afford a gun probably revolver no okay
we're just gonna go again not like we
lose any money going this point
pink punk
we're already gaining a lot of speed
come on get lucky come on come on head
may want you to do it I don't have the
energy I just did a workout and Wolf all
right I'm just gonna do this a whole
bunch to get up some beginning money
until I can actually do something worth
getting whoa
later on the game gets kind of
ridiculous because it just takes so long
for your turtle just never mind it
doesn't take long at all for your turtle
to stop floating bags of money
throughout the city I mean I I kind of
want to live here and at the same time I
really don't because I see the
dilapidated state of everything in the
background shut up Pelican douche why
don't you come swoop me up and drop me
somewhere actually judging by the rate
you're going I don't want you to do that
at all all right what can we do nothing
ooh rock back I'd like to sender that I
got a rocket now okay I don't know how I
forget how to use the rocket oops
bad how do I use the rocket again I
forget oh there we go I gotta click on
it that's a little bizarre hey that kids
have done okay that gets even farther so
yeah this is like the whole game but you
think this is the whole game well then
right because that's what you do you
toss turtle and then you keep it going
all right
I'm just getting metals over and over
again because I haven't logged in all
right
we don't give this
this is like this is like my childhood
and just playing in the computer lab
over and over again because I wasn't
gonna do the works at this side why
would I do that that's completely stupid
I mean I once got caught playing the
impossible game a whopping time ago in a
lab that was fun I didn't get very far
nice nice nice nice and another one okay
don't hit anything then just hit the
ground I guess I see occasionally you
get like everything the Stars will align
and you get everything that you
absolutely need I mean that didn't do a
whole lot but I'll take it just a little
extra dab add my hands yes and now we
can buy an upgrade we can get an
upgraded cannon I'm very sweaty by the
way because it's extremely hot in here
the air conditioner is not working so I
just got to power through everything so
I'm gonna get another cannon and now
we're gonna be able to go even holy crap
holy crap
oh we're super high okay I think I need
to rethink where I put my rocket then if
I'm gonna be remiss you son of a [ __ ]
okay I think I got shot by guns but it
exploded oh this is amazing oh yes yeah
yes come on give me some good
give me some garden give me anything
good anything will do it all
oh yes I'll take that nice big bomb big
baby bomb what's that bomb a baby
it had a buck just like a baby did oh it
is a big baby bomb it's a big adorable
baby bomb it's been a long time I don't
even remember all the stuff that's here
just a few more hello goodbye
oh I don't remember that at all that was
awesome
I got sure you can buy a banana don't
say that every day oh it's so hot in
there oh okay then what did I tell you
not to do god dangus oh god exploded
right into the spikes yeah alright so I
have enough money for another upgrade
and I think the upgrade is gonna be a
gun next because I can buy the Uzi and I
don't know weak but lots of ammo with
low accuracy I don't know if that's
gonna help alright so it is powerful but
less bullets or more bullets and less
power I'm gonna go with the desert eagle
because that sounds amazing
okay got it let's try it out let's see
what this does very lateral motion here
and oh sorry sorry can you pick
something in midair to be really really
appreciated here if you could just hit a
damn thing without my what okay anyway
damn I am breaking a kind of a record
here Wow nice
oh I went five miles did I not bad not
bad at all
oh [ __ ] bad don't do that now what I'm
trying to make a record here nice nice
nice
noise oh we're flying really far on this
one this is gonna be another record
because I just so happened to get but
it's helping me a lot
boink don't hit the ground you bastard
you totally well I don't know where I
went holy crap oh my god still have
bullets left oh lordy oh my god this is
a good one it's a good one okay so we're
out of bullets where are we gonna go oh
no no don't do that okay all right we're
back we're back on track
oh I almost lost it there accidently hit
the scroll wheel and move the mouse off
oh okay hey I'm a professional I'm a
professional what I have no idea
professional slacker oh don't hit spikes
do not hit spikes do not hit spikes
you've got two good two thing going on
here oh I didn't know that a hundred
feet was in space but I'll take it
there's a lot of other games that are
like this like launch the Hedgehog is
another one of my favorites and I might
play that guys if you play that one if
you guys want me to it's a really fun
game there's a lot of really fun flash
games out there that I'd love to show
you because they're all just little
pieces of my childhood and not even my
childhood like most of my adulthood was
spent playing these games cuz they're so
cool oh this is a record I'm not gonna
be for a long time yeah how was a good
one oh oh we're still going apparently
just a little bit just a little bit more
had too much fun on that one huh how
much money did I get woo not bad
hello oh I'm sorry oh okay oh okay
I was just busy taking a little drink
there and then everything decided to go
crazy on me all right oh whoops
okay so I have enough that I can buy the
jet pack and I'm pretty sure that's
gonna propel me for Paul me propulsion
me much farther than this initial jet
pack was good good good good go go go go
go go go go
that wasn't bad not bad at all wink see
how far that gets me in the end
I mean I'm going a lot faster than I was
before there we go now we're getting
sassy at some point I'm gonna feel bad
about shooting a turtle out of the sky
but today is not that day I see a lot of
those spike balloons that are just eager
to hit something holy crap
okay back down we go this turtle has
been through some [ __ ] this turtle has
experienced some stuff that we mortal
minds can't even comprehend boink
keep going baby oh I had bullets left
huh nuclear bombs are dangerous but who
cares they make huge explosion you can
buy more what if I won I have no idea
what its gonna do but I've always
enjoyed the idea of having a nuke
just on standby what does it do Oh
where am i oh god I didn't know that
that's what it was gonna do oh lordy
whoa boy and we've broken every rep I'm
pretty sure we've broke it absolutely
every record so if we hit something
it'll be good
nope it the ground great and dodged
everything can we break a hundred
thousand can we break a hundred thousand
please tell me we're gonna break under
the Hudson but it was amazing
maybe I don't know boom yes will you
broke a hundred thousand I'm shocked
there's not an achievement for that but
I did it
sorry my hair is an absolute mess I just
come down the shower I come to come
never mind
okay so we finally have enough for
another upgrade and that means we're
gonna get the super cannon which is
gonna make us go even farther it's got
lights
it's got seizure-inducing lights go baby
go boom whoa we're going way faster now
I love it I see all these bullets flying
by but they ain't doing me no good
apparently yeah this is amazing oh come
on don't know what I hit there anything
nothing yeah we're not gonna get
record-breaking unless we get another
nuke which is gonna cost another ten
grand but I have a feeling we're gonna
make that money up very soon because of
the distances that were covered
what the hell is going on I have no idea
I'm just being here messing with my hair
and everything is going crazy on me no
more bullets Oh miss all of those bombs
I miss the bomb party never get invited
to the bomb party not quite record
breaking but still pretty dang good okay
that's the end of ours but still very
very good run very good run if we can
keep that up it's good awesome we
brought a hat we broke a height record
oh god oh yeah I ran out of bullets but
I hit it holy crap I can't believe I hit
that go me go oh fudge okay we're gonna
sort of Liza's here Wow I don't know
what we hit it was going by too fast I
heard a chainsaw and then some other
explosions and how was the end of it
whoa we smile we smashed the record yeah
holy crap it's so cool oh another one
another one oh no you can't end it like
that
so abruptly oh that's so sad
what else can I get I guess I can get
another guellen-- let's see reach 25,000
feet but that's no good I don't want a
limited reach
I won't unlimited reach that's stupid
can't even get another gun anyway you
know what this is actually I should have
bought the Uzi business actually its
power is higher than the Desert Eagle
anyway and it's got more than twice as
much ammo I'm gonna get that because
that seems way better it's got no
limitation on the distance which is good
next up I'm gonna get the gold cannon
I'm gonna do a move um I think actually
this is probably the better strategy to
go about this because I'm getting a lot
of distance you don't get me wrong but
what I'm gonna do next is uh the only
problem is that I'm losing speed because
I'm going so high and the only reason
that I'm going high is because I'm
hitting these high up obstacles which
lot may be like super up and that's
actually costing me so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna save my rocket until after
I'm out of bullets because my bullets
can keep them at about in the hundred
range of distance pipe and then that way
I'll be able to keep going are there
farther longer and then hopefully get
another high score
it's where all my concentration gets
used utilize now
oh yes that's what I wanted that's what
I wanted now we got the speed oh never
mind we hit something anyway and we went
into orbit I don't know what the hell we
get but damn it my plan didn't work
fudge or nutters ow
I hit a Sun up there apparently up in
the sky I hit another star
I was orbiting the galaxy and I just so
happened to go far enough that I ran
into another star great good thing good
to know this turtle can go to light
speed
Oh gate will reset this will get this
will get this forget this yeah Bank
oh I nailed that yes see what I did
there is I reset my altitude by using
the rocket strategically
okay nevermind altitude Bend Wow I hit a
Sun up there apparently up in the sky I
hit another star
I was orbiting the galaxy and I just so
happened to go far enough that I've ran
into another star great good thing good
to know this turtle can go to light
speed oh I hit 20 spikes how good for me
okay now I have enough money for both
the gold Canon and a nuclear thingy we
don't know what the nuclear thing is but
wow that is phallic like okay
let's see how this go 3 2 holy crap
Oh holy Wow I don't know when I'm gonna
use a nuke but I have a feeling it
should be right about now oh I mean it's
very still holy crap gotta say I've
gotta say up oh my God we're gonna set a
record we are going to set a record oh
we are gonna oh man we were gonna
shatter our records what we're gonna do
if we get lucky on things we hit and we
don't hit a floating spike which is
entirely possible knowing my luck I hit
something up there I don't know what
okey-dokey then
yes oh we're gonna break 200,000 we
might even break 300,000 if we keep this
up oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh hot damn whoo
don't mess this one up Marky move don't
mess this one up Marky move you got
plenty of bullets just leave it last
leave it last okay leave it lastly
velasco go go yes world's edge 50 miles
even though I went to another star
that's literally light-years away at
least I got that three hundred thousand
has been broken that is a new world
record let's see how far we can go with
this
two more bullets come on be judicial
about this we're about to break 400,000
oh we're gonna break 400,000 don't hit a
spike yes okay it's in fates hands now I
have no control over anything anymore
unless I magically get more bullets
which I don't think I will
oh wow that might be farther than I've
actually ever gone in this game because
I don't even remember what I did way
back in the day even though this isn't -
way back in the day I think this came
out no.9 I have no idea but damn damn
damn that is far is this a n though this
is the end is this where we stop is this
where we hit a spike and then come to a
sudden and very sad and depressing halt
well looks like that's all she wrote I
think the game is actually breaking
because there's no screen left to
generate I've already gone so many miles
at the road that was close spike alright
so this looks like it's gonna be the end
for this we're gonna see how much money
we make from this but thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
have not played toss the turtle play it
it's amazing baby and there's a whole
bunch of other games that are like it
that are super fun I highly recommend
Newgrounds because it's where I went for
all my cool games and where I saw all
these cool animation creators and all
sorts of cool creative personalities
like congregated there and the sights
still alive so you can see all kinds of
new stuff being created there every day
I'm not advertising for new grounds I
just really
of my life so thank you everybody so
much for watching I really thought I
would have stopped by now so let's just
wait and see no I'm gonna hit one more
there we go just one last thing
okay we're still going apparently oh god
why Wow oh we got I got twenty four
thousand dollars in cash bags
I got seventy three thousand dollars in
one amazing run my high score of four
hundred and seventy five thousand feet
see if you can beat that let me know if
you do in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
play this game there's a link in the
description and see how the cool flash
games that I played in the past thanks
again everybody and as always I will see